this was the first time when you started
making this movie this was like your
first time seeing Tracy since his
accident
yeah and I'm curious it must have been
personally great to see him like he's
he's back he's healthy it's always great
to see Tracy you know uh was great
nobody got pregnant on the movie great
and it's cool because now you just tell
me how rich he is now
oh wait pregnant I did actually get for
you yeah we do got a pregnancy you know
tell me how rich he is now I got hit by
a truck they paid me cute is that what
you do you go around talking about how
much money you got yes amen he said
thank God I didn't get hit by a George
boss discount furniture
[Laughter]
coupons discount and got the money yeah
yeah yeah
you